hello everyone welcome back to the kappa
blanka saga we are back at round seven
over the 1914 tournament in some feature
burg its host our world cup of vodka
versus Aussie Bernstein now if you've
been following the couple Blanc of saga
from the beginning you know that it was
awesome Bernstein who first protested
against kappa blanka even joining in the
1911 tournament of san sebastian and
then capablanca defeated him in a
beautiful fashion and he won the
brilliance price for that game in the
1911 tournaments of San Sebastian
so here Bernstein again with the black
pieces has an opportunity here but this
time he does not face someone who has
never proven himself here to here he
faces pretty much the favorite to win
even the 1914 tournament in
sankt-petersburg
but ok his kappa blanka said himself he
wasn't feeling all that great and he had
Alaska and the Rubinstein as favorites
for this tournament before I show you
the game one fun story I was at the
hairdresser today and there were these
wallpapers on the wall and a half on one
half of the wall and there were articles
from from the newspapers and I thought
yeah ok they're probably not real
articles they were probably just you
know imaginary or computer generator
something but I started reading and it
you know seemed like a real article and
there were you know a lot of them and
then I checked the year and the year was
there were some from 1913 and on the
other part of the world were some from
1914 and I thought it'd be it'd be super
cool if I could see an actual article
from the 1914 tournament some Peterburg
there at the wall of my hairdresser but
unfortunately that was not the case as
much as I looked there was no evidence
of any any chess on the wall but I did
find the one a very nice article it was
pretty much a clickbait article from
1919 13 about a Hudson 33 car that you
should really get it and that 2,000
people have already missed an under
opportunity to get this car which is
just amazing so yeah that's that's how
you know how long ago clickbait was used
but of course even even much prior to
that but okay and getting back to this
game a couple banca has the white pieces
and this game I'm not gonna say anything
but
you're gonna enjoy it a cup of Blanc
opens with d4 with d5 Knight to f3
Knight to f6 and c4 now we have East 6
the Queens gambit declined is on the
board and now Knight to c3 Knight B to
d7 and here Bishop to g5 and here there
are a couple of ways you could play this
line with black you generally want to
wait till white develops the light
square Bishop then you want to capture
and c4 push b5 or you could just
continue developing play Bishop e7
develop the Queen to c7 once the C pawn
moves and then push be 5 so those are
some general ideas and here it's very
interesting how Bernstein and goes about
goes about this defense as he was not to
be one of the better defenders of that
age but sorry not King g7 Bishop to e7
we have III by capablanca preparing to
develop the light square bishop we have
c6 now and Bishop to d3 and here
Bernstein now takes the opportunity to
force the bishop to loose Tempe we have
D captures on c4 Bishop captures on c4
and now comes b5 and okay this is we
already mentioned that you could use
this D captures on c4 to make your
advancements on the Queen side as the
bishop is now somewhat misplaced this is
all very much known measure back to d3
and now a 6 we have a 4 e 4 by kappa
blanka are preparing e5 of course and
here Bernstein takes a very interesting
approach
he plays d5 he doesn't want to allow
kappa blanka to push see 5 himself the
better better idea here would have been
c5 to tackle the center affront from the
Queen side here he plays d5 a temporary
pawn sacrifice Capablanca accepts it D
captures on e5 and now comes Knight to
g4 offering some trades which is
something you usually want to do in this
in this system of the Queen's in sort of
the Queens gambit declined Bishop Bishop
to f4 capablanca does not straight here
as he now wants to keep his pawn on e5
and he asks Bernstein what what's your
plan here we have Bishop to c5 now
pressuring the f2 poem Capablanca
castles so there's no more threat of
capturing an f2 and here Queen to c7 and
it seems that Bernstein figured
everything out both of the Knights are
attacking d5
also the queen is pressuring d5 pawn
bursting got some nice development for
the price of for the temporary price of
one pawn and well couple Monica's bone
structure in the century is somewhat
messed up so there there are
compensation there is compensation here
but he forgot one very important thing
and that's I'm Captain Jack Sparrow I'm
just kidding of course he forgot that
kappa blanka is a brilliant player and
here a cup of manga please look the c1
and now there are problems here what's
the problem if you decide to capture the
pawn now for example night D captures on
e5 then you get Knight captures on e5
Knight captures and now you get Queen to
h5 and here's a somewhat somewhat of a
problem you cannot play f6 to defend the
night because the pawn is pinned if you
try to kick the Queen away with g6 you
lose the night here so here
black would have to go brush up to d4
but now you finally see the idea behind
the rook to see one now Knight the d5 is
an option because of course the the pawn
cannot capture the Queen and c7 would be
lost
Queen to d6 still defending this Knight
and now finally rook captures on c6 this
is where the magic happens Queen
captures on c6 and only now Bishop
captures on e5 threatening to win
another piece but also going after the
g7 pawn Bishop captures Queen captures
with check now you cannot go King to
effect or something like that because
you get Queen e7 check and then it's
just
checkmate here Queen capture sunny it
would be checkmate so after this Queen
captures on e5 you would have to block
Bishop to e6 and now Queen captures on
g7 will just be deadly for white for
example rook to f8 you don't want to
lose your rook Knight to f6 check King
t7 and now comes a e5 and here it seems
like black is possibly defending because
he's up material but not really
after the rook is moved a rook to e4
Bishop to b4 is the threat for for this
very nice attack but then after the rock
moves you would get Queen to g5 this
very nice move threatening all sorts of
nasty discoveries the knight is
controlling D squares so the King has
nowhere to move the point is controlling
these six and here it would just be a
you know a slow suffocating death for
black
so after this rook to see one move of
brilliant move by capablanca he he
tackled this early e5 idea by Bernstein
over the board so to say here we have f6
Bernstein decides to go about this this
way as the Bishop on f4 is unguarded so
Capablanca cannot capture on f6 due to
Queen captures on f4 but capablanca
plays a different idea we have Bishop to
g3
and now finally we have F captures on e4
on e5 and here it seems okay Bernstein
now has some excellent development this
Knight is ready to come all the way to
f6 the king will Castle the bishop can
then be developed and Bernstein is no
longer down upon so it seems everything
is all right but not really here couple
blanca finds once again just just a
brilliant move I could ask you to find
it but I will first first show you the
brilliant move and I will only then ask
you to continue couple Blancas
brilliancy here kappa blanka played
before and now you see the real power of
the rook to see one move coupled Blanca
figured everything out this was the real
plan and now what happens here if if
Bishop captures on before which is
called long cosplay and then comes
Knight d5 once again and after the Queen
has to defend the bishop on b4 Queen d6
now comes Knight captures on d4 Queen
captures and now rook captures on c6 and
here a white will just be white would
just be too strong here look at the c7
will be a suffocating move for black if
you develop then rook the c7 attacks the
bishop forces the King to yet stay
longer without castling as the knight
would also be attacked and if you don't
do this if you just castile still rook
to c7 such a powerful move white is just
white is just so much better here so
after this b4 move Bernstein does not
capture it he goes Bishop to e7
but this is the position cup of Blanca
actually wanted so first
Bernstein doesn't and doesn't go for
this first strap doesn't go for the
second trap but now feel free to pause
the video here and try to find a couple
bunkers a real idea in this position
here I'll give you a couple of seconds
as it's really just just a beautiful
idea everything started with the move
to see one for those who were able to do
it congratulations you are an amazing
player you know just creating brilliance
is wherever you go and for those who
just wanna enjoy the show here not
Knight d5 but rather Bishop captures
from b5 just forcing black the deal with
the loss of material and here there are
a couple of ways you could go about this
one way is to just well capture the
bishop button there are there aren't
really all that many ideas you there are
some ideas with Knights the e3 forcing
white to the first capture the knight
but it all leads the severe material
loss for black so here Bernstein
accepted the bishop it captures and now
comes Knight captures on b5 so yes a
bishop sacrifice but you grab two very
important points on the Queen side but
also Black has to react
you cannot capture the pony still pinned
the Queen is under attack we have Queen
to d8 and now comes Knight to d6 check
and this is a very important move
because once again we have to go to the
famous book about this tournament by a
written by Ziggler Tara Tara wrote here
that Knight to d6 is a is a very strong
move but that rook captures and c6 would
have given a victory sooner but there's
there's the problem and it's very
interesting now it's easy I'm making
this video in 2019 I had to say how Tara
show is wrong about this as we have all
the engines in the world that just give
us answer straight away but it's
interesting that as a Tarrasch was
writing a book after the tournament of
course he analyzed the positions over
the board and it's interesting that
capablanca chose the exact strongest
variation over the board and tarish when
analyzing the position you know later at
home to prepare some lines for his book
found a lesser line and it's very
interesting this rook captures on c6
move this is the variation Alaska gives
in his book that now after black castles
we have Queen to d5 check getting the
Queen in line with the rook that is
undefended on a8 and after King to h8
now on to h3 wins material because after
the knight moves rook captures knight
Knight captures and now white just picks
up the rug
is undefended on a8 but the problem with
starch idea is that after King to h8 and
h3 black does not have to go back with
Knight to f6 black can actually play
Knight captures on f2 and now parish
would actually be able to really
complicate life for kappa blanka because
after Bishop captures you would get
Bishop captures would check rook
captures and now Bishop the b7 attacking
the rook here so nice the d6 now comes
bushel captures rook Queen captures on
c6 and now the idea that most likely was
overlooked by by tariff when doing the
book I think he most likely has gotten
this far is actually Queen to b6 giving
up in the night on d7 and after Queen
captures now comes rook captures on a to
threatening Queen captures and checkmate
on g2 so after night to f7 check King to
g8 mountain night to h6 check with the
idea that if the knight is captured the
Queen d5 check will pick up the rock on
a2 then the King has to go back King h8
and now finally Knight to g4 white would
be able to defend the rook but now comes
h5 in the knight is under attack Queen
to e7 now sorry Queen to e7 now going
after the rook on f8 King to g8 and now
comes Queen captures on e5 there is
nothing to do with the night you cannot
protect it you cannot move it Queen
captures and now H captures on g4 and
here white would actually have nothing
better than go for a perpetual which
Queen to defy check King to h8 sorry not
to Queen d5 check but rather not Queen
if the east sorry Queen d5 check King
moves and now Queen to h5 check we would
get this perpetual so in fact the move
capablanca played Knight to d6 check is
the strongest and the only correct way
to go for a victory here the move teres
chose is is not working due to had the
fact that after h3
Knight doesn't have to go back simply
Knight capture it's a very complicated
line but it's just amazing that
capablanca found Knight b6 to be the
strongest over the board or maybe he was
just lazy to calculate rook rook
captures on c6 it's you know we'll never
know
ok King
fate and now comes Luke captures on c6
now night captors on f2 is pointless
because white can simply ignore you the
night from d6 also covers f7 Queen b3
comes with the threat of checkmate and
now after a black protects against
checkmate as there are no useful
discoveries for black to be made here
special characters and you don't just
you know grab that night nothing nothing
good is happening here for black but
okay after Luke the c6 nights the b6 now
a further protection of the bishop and
c8 is needed and the now comes Bishop to
h4 attacking a Bernstein's Queen Queen
to d7 and now finally a couple Blanca
goes for the easiest idea Knight
captures on c8 and here if you play
something like Queen captures on d1 you
get this live rook captures on d1 now
comes Luke captures on c8 rook captures
with Czech Knight captures and now the
problem for black rook the d8 check King
has to move and now you pick up the rook
here after the knight moves as the
knight is under attack now you play h3
and now d5 pawn falls as well Knight of
6 Knight captures and black is just
falling apart and also white is up you
know planting material so after Knight
to c8 we have Queen captures and c6
Bernstein grabs the rook but now we have
Queen to d8 check and this is what
Bernstein had to allow to avoid that
losing endgame Queen to d8 check we have
Queen to yet blocking and here again a
very nice move although instead of this
Queen to d8 check Capablanca again had a
different light he aligned he could have
gone for a much quicker line but again
it's probably you know Capablanca finds
the line that wins and he doesn't look
for faster lines as you know he does
have to reach time control but you're
you know enjoying yourself in your home
I feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the clicker line Capablanca
could have played you know once again
for those who were able to do it
congratulations on creating these
brilliant sees wherever you go Bishop to
e7 check is much quicker because now
okay if you go to the back rank then
comes Queen to d8 but then you have to
go to King to f7
so now Knight g5
King to g6 and now finally as the night
opened the path here Queen captures on
g4 Queen captures on c8 now offering to
trade Queens but not nice the e6 check
King to f7 Queen captures on g7 King
captures an e6 and now rook to d1
prepares checkmate and there's no good
defense against this black would have to
start giving material but then pawn
captures King has to move and then Queen
f6 check King e4 and Queen to f3 will be
checkmate but any other line leads to
checkmate just as well so this is one
very nice line but capablanca finds a
different one
not Bishop to e7 first but rather Queen
to d8 check and okay we have Quinta e8
blocking and now Bishop to e7 check King
to f7 and now Knight to d6 check
attacking the Queen and the king so a
very nice form but also cuppa Blancas
queen is under attack but this is what
couple Blanca finds King to g6 now comes
Knight to h4 check King to h5 night the
yet grabbing the Queen now rook captures
Queen so Bernstein also grabs Kappa
Blancas Queen and now Knight captures
and g7 would check King to h6 and now
Knight G to f5 with check the King has a
very few squares h5 the only available
square now King to h5 and now h3 and now
you can see that there is no way nowhere
to play the night if you go f6 the
bishop or captured if you go to h6 then
you have taken away the h6 square from
your king then Knight the g3 or Knight
to g7 will be checkmated the King has
nowhere to go
very nice so after h3 we have Knight to
c8 Bernie has to try something H
captures on g4 with check King captures
and now Bishop captures on the 8th
finally rook captures on d8 and now
comes the g3 and this is the position
most likely Capablanca so man he decided
to play the earth Queen to the 8th check
if there was nothing better he most
likely would have looked for Bishop to
e7 check but there was no need as here
capablanca has a winning endgame he's up
three pawns and the opponent's king is
just in a terrible position waiting to
be to be you know don't just dominated
rook to d2 was played by bernstein going
after the a to pawn
King to g2 and not not capturing
immediately because white would just
continue night is three night captures
on e5 first look to e to going after the
e4 pawn but Capablanca doesn't mind with
a four and now comes Knight the b6 black
wants to activate Knights - III King to
h5 and now comes a five attacking the
knight Knight to d7 and not Knight h 2f
v we have Knight to f6 there's not much
black and do here black is just trying
something but you know b5 b6 is coming
so we have B 5 and now preparing b6 so
rush up to d4 you don't want to allow
your Bishop to remain there we have King
to f3 capablanca even decides the
defender for pawn we have grouped to a2
now comes a 5 protecting the a5 pawn
bishop to a7 now okay the bishop is now
controlling the pawns on on the light
squares now look the c1
now the rook is coming into the into the
game we have looked a bit too and now g4
with check King to g5 and now rook to c7
attacking the bishop
we have rook and Soria I mean here
Bernstein can just resign there's
there's no really no good move here but
instead of resigning Bernstein decided
to play a few more moves here you know
perhaps just so it seemed is that
Capablanca took longer to take him down
he played rook captures on f2 for some
reason King captures and Knight captures
in g4 okay it's a little nifty line the
knight is pinned okay you cannot capture
but after Capablanca played King to f3
it was in this position that awesome
Bernstein resigned the game and
Capablanca won this brilliant brilliant
game so not only did he beat Bernstein
in the 1911 Sun Sebastiaan tournament
and proved to him and everyone by
winning that game against him and the
entire tournament
that he definitely deserves to be bitter
but now also in Round seven of the 1914
song featured books tournament he
creates this brilliancy against the same
opponent who protested against him three
years ago showing him who's the boss
yeah and not only that before this game
was played two games prior to that Tasha
was supposed to get a brilliant surprise
for his game against nimzowitsch and
people were you know in tournament
organizers who were considering that
game for the brilliancy prize but when
they saw this game kappa blanka played
the brilliancy prize in this tournament
was awarded to capablanca for his game
against Austin Bernstein here and it's
just brilliant how how this entire game
from the opening from this Bishop e7
move
Bernstein just you know mixes up lines
goes B 5 and E 5 in the same line which
is not something you can do and
capablanca takes advantage of it just
brilliantly and it's a it's a position
that's I mean this line is played even
today so you should remember it if
someone goes this temporary pawn
sacrifice against it's very unlikely but
you know just so you know rope to see
one here just deadly winning the tears
there's no way for black to escape all
the threats after this rook the c1 is
actually the real brilliance in this
game how about everything else that
follows is you know just as well but ok
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and yeah I would like to thank David
Kaiser a raffle so large
Paul Staples mark gamble and Andrew
D'Amato for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check too on my
previous video see or think all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Capablanca saga checking
up on Leela and the match against ox
which is almost over and you know of
course checking on your hashtag
suggestions thank you all and have an
excellent rest of your day and see you
soon